[Music]
in this video we're going to walk
through the various google cloud vmware
engine screens and get familiar with all
the different capabilities available my
name is raj jitnani with google cloud
and in this video we're going to go
through a walkthrough of the vmware
engine portal
here as you can see we've got our
resource summary
capacity summary and common tasks to
launch and perform within the
environment
let's take a closer look at our
resources and private clouds already
deployed
here we have our current private cloud
with a summary information on the
current name of the private cloud the
operational status as well as things
like the location where it's deployed
our management side of range
and our vcenter and nsxd login
information
in the next section we have our capacity
in terms of a number of nodes deployed
how much cpu memory and storage are
currently available
and below that are our versions for the
vmware components
finally at the bottom here we have the
ability to delete a private cloud
we have the ability to remove nodes as
needed
and the ability to elevate permissions
of a local user account or a a.d tied
user account
this is useful for certain
administrative tasks that require
additional permissions on your
management components such as vcenter
next let's take a look at the clusters
view
which will list out all the clusters we
have available
and also allow us to apply auto scale
policies
for the environment
so if we wanted to be able to auto scale
up or down depending on resource usage
we can do so in this screen and there
are different policies available
depending on the situation
that you may encounter or your
application requirements
one thing to note you can also add nodes
manually by clicking the add node button
here
and adding a node to your existing
cluster or creating a brand new cluster
within your private cloud next let's
take a look at the vsphere management
network view
where we can see the urls for all our
management components ip addresses as
well as versions associated with them
keep in mind that
one of the benefits of running a vmware
service such as google cloud vmware
engine is these components are managed
by google cloud so any updates patches
security releases
are configured and released by google
cloud directly under the advanced
vcenter section we can add a remote
syslog server so you can forward your
vcenter logs to a syslog server of your
choice
and under the dns configuration we have
the ability to add dns profiles so that
the management components can find your
on-prem environment as an example
so if you have an on-prem domain that
you would like to resolve
you can go ahead and enter
that domain information here and we'll
be able to resolve that from the vcenter
object and other management components
next let's take a look at the network
section
where you can perform network tasks such
as enabling firewall rules
viewing the subnets assigning public ips
to your workloads such as any web
servers that you might have enabling a
vpn gateway so you can vpn into this
environment and the private connection
view this is an important view where you
can actually peer
your gcve environment to an existing
google cloud project
so if you need any google cloud
components to reach
google cloud vmware engine
we can plug in the information here and
be able to communicate directly
more details on this step in another
video
next let's take a look at the regional
settings view and this is where we're
able to add the ability for your
workloads to egress into the internet
and also
assign public ip addresses to them next
let's take a look at the activity view
where we can see any alerts associated
with the environment
events
tasks that have occurred in the
environment as well as an audit trail of
all activity within the google cloud
vmware engine portal
under account we have the ability here
to see the summary of the environment as
well as add additional emails
and users so that they can be alerted
when things like a new private cloud is
created a note is being replaced
or if you want our google cloud vmware
engine support team to be able to access
this portal for troubleshooting purposes
that's a quick walkthrough of the portal
thanks for watching
to learn more about google cloud vmware
engine visit our site at
cloud.google.com
vmware dash engine
[Music]
you